welcome to CBS this morning we're gonna
start this morning in Hong Kong where
there is a standoff at one of Hong
Kong's universities where protesters are
facing a new ultimatum from police
demonstrators who spent days trying to
keep police from getting into the campus
are now desperately trying to get out
this morning police use tear gas and
rubber bullets on students and called on
them to surrender and it's just one of
many flash points in the run-up to a new
election in Hong Kong scheduled for this
Sunday
ramie inocencia is outside the
Polytechnic University in Hong Kong
that's an urban campus there so Raymond
what are you seeing there right now good
morning four to five hundred
anti-government demonstrators are
believed to be barricaded in the red
brick buildings right behind me they
have been in the standoff for the past
few days now as you said they are
encircled by police pretty much
everywhere on the roads and on the
bridges all around here but looking
ahead these protestors say they don't
want to leave in part because they want
to keep fighting and they're also afraid
of getting arrested please push past
student barricades and into Hong Kong's
prestigious Polytechnic University smoke
filled the air as they chase down
protesters escorting some away in
handcuffs
if the protesters do not initiate the
use of force the police will not
initiate the use of force early Monday
the university's president appealed to
protesters to abandon violence but as
some students attempted to leave the
campus
they were treated in the face of
approaching law enforcement it's the
culmination of a day's long standoff
police armed with riot gear tear gas and
water cannons and students station
behind homemade barricades equipped with
makeshift catapults slingshots and
petrol bombs at one point protesters
forced a police vehicle to turn back
after hitting it with a flurry of
explosive fire some were even seen with
bows and arrows and photos show an arrow
piercing an officer's leg
these protesters attacked an ambulance
in an effort to free an injured woman
who was also under arrest
any harm and this protester identified
only as Matthew said I do want to leave
but I won't because there are still a
lot of people here and it is not safe
now in a press conference earlier police
said that protesters targeting officers
are committing a murderous act so far
about 40 people have already been
arrested in this standoff that has been
going on for more than 24 hours now
looking ahead this campus this
University along with universities
across the territory are set to close
for tomorrow and possibly for the rest
of this week Jericka all right continues
to escalate their rainy innocencio force
in Hong Kong thank you